[Music]
I know you're trying to get us onto you
the trouble now of course not it could
have been confiscated what does that
mean take it away
worse you could have been lost no no no
guys listen Bonnie had a great day in
class and we're going on a road trip
road trip JJ did something really weird
happened Bonnie made a friend in class
oh no no no she literally made a new
friend hey it's okay come on out that's
it let's get you out of there you got
this four key Wendy why am i alive you
are a toy you belong to Bonnie these are
your friends woody I have a question um
well actually not just one I have all
the questions who wants to go on a road
trip you need help with that no no I got
it
I know this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
four key buzz
we gotta get quite Roger that
[Music]
change of plans Jessie ah but both Rex
potato hey watch it buddy let's go save
a spork
do I need to be worried my guys are
veterans they'll hang in there
Oh
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man oh
yeah posing yeah do you cling hold on
one more oh yeah
what do you'll save me I've known that
guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
oh is that how we look on the inside
there's so much body needs for kids Oh
sheriff what are you always come into
the rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
Duke for me
let's kaboom
four keys being kept how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go oh where did you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]
[Music]